Jeremy because I gotta speak because I  got a friend and she's been in the  church for like I don't know about 30  years and she ain't got no man and you  know what she never went to church  looking for no man so she don't expect  to go because she never went to church  with funny trauma do you know what I  mean so she always went to church she  said if a man that was a man if a man  comes along fine I never it's a eunuch  that's the word and if a man doesn't  come along I said to her you're a unit  he goes why are you putting it on that  me I've still got time to find the man  that's in this one give up mine now  you're eunuch do you know what I mean  some women go to church and they're  going to church thinking that yeah all  women are supposed to find men in church  no some of the women are supposed to be  single in church